we're learning more this morning about a
hero Transit worker down in Washington
D.C who was killed when he tried to stop
a gunman from shooting at commuters
authorities say the Rampage began on a
city bus and it ended at a metro train
station when passengers disarmed the
shooter our Scott McFarland has the
details
just a mile from the U.S Capitol a
gunman targeted commuters Wednesday I
just saw all the police cars dashing and
dashing chasing then shooting a fellow
passenger coming off a city bus the man
then went inside a DC Metro Rail Station
where police say he shot another person
in the legs Witnesses said he was on an
indiscriminate Rampage somebody run down
on the platform and shoot three people
it's just unheard of it's it's crazy I
have a man shot looks like in his head
according to police when the shooter
confronted a woman near the tracks
that's when 64 year old mechanic Robert
Cunningham tried to intervene and was
killed his heroism has to be recognized
here today police said civilians were
the ones to tackle the suspect before
officers arrived and took the man into
custody I think they save lives and
that's to be commended but the fact that
our citizens have to intervene with
armed gunman is is disturbing to me
late last night police identified their
suspect 31-year-old Isaiah trotman of
Washington D.C charged with first-degree
murder while armed and CBS News has
learned the Transit Union late last year
warned the Transit Agency they worried
about being targeted or victimized by
acts of violence Gail
thank you very much Scott